[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've been expecting you
jihadi Bond I was wondering what took
you so long to find me let's just say I
was well I hope she knows how to handle
that left hook of yours she did
unfortunately for her it was the right
you've always had a way of the ladies
double six six well that's simply
because I always understood something
you could not and what's that what you
call charm I call draping and repeatedly
and beating them without mercy to put
that my notebook of pick up tips Mr Bond
enough small talk who are you working
for who is behind this mug club you're
gonna stop it besides it's not who it's
what those wheels are already motion of
force which cannot be stopped
we'll see what YouTube has to say about
this my club is a force beyond YouTube
it cannot be contained it cannot be
stopped
do you really think that you do with all
its power with all its featured content
with all its Young Turks they cannot
take care of your merry band of friends
what happens when your precious mug Club
is banned or worse they monetize my club
operates outside of YouTube outside
YouTube but that's Internet suicide
you're a right Mr Bond
YouTube merely provides shall we say the
platform to grow bugs love as YouTube
continues this jihad of free speech
effectively using its own power against
itself as users continue to join my club
YouTube is no longer needed to reach
ones user base it is suicide jihadi bond
with YouTube's finger on the trigger
I've heard enough who is behind this
supposedly unstoppable mug clubs you
still don't get it it is not who it's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I just realized that totally reverse
that you're supposed to do the inflate
which was my dad used to do that when I
was a kid and to embarrass me because I
was weak and skinny speaking of which
not gay Jer introducing with me in a
video studio as always I was near the
gym this week that's good
homers time in a year and half follow
him at knock hey Jer and me at s Crowder
with your comments questions photoshop's
insults I fulfill my legal obligations
draw your own conclusions we good we're
good yeah that's right it's not good you
went to the gym I did but I'll see my
energy easy so that's the worst like if
you're planning on going to the gym and
you buy a new toy yeah I get a new gun
or you you get a recliner it's like
let's say the two conflicts just don't
plan anything fun the same day numb
speaking of which at G Morgan Jr here
fun game not fun house and you're fun
because you're a wine guy you have one
full grown human being to ask me truth
in comedy use six foot five giants fit
him in the studio great guests today we
have bas Rutten mixed martial arts
legend closet conservative but after
this he'll be lucky to work again in the
entertainment history and then of course
we have Andrew Clavin great friend of
the show how many curries have we killed
now yeah seven this is the death chart
of four launched Japan well let him come
out I have a few things I want to ask
him about which sort of implies it we
have some stories that we'll be talking
about the replace and repeal the bill
the health care bill went through with
single-digit votes today but that's a
big deal and there's a lot of outrage
from the left over the Upton amendment
so I know it's kind of boring it's
convoluted we'll get into that though
and hopefully I'll explain it in a way
that you can understand it also Bill Nye
fake news chromosomes and the gender
bender will talk about that what's true
what's not true I'm certainly no [ __ ]
Bane is coming up to us Tremaine
trainee Bane is debuting today if you
have them if you're not Oh Z crap
you don't want to do with [ __ ] baby
details so before we get to those
stories are there a couple of stories
that just that you know piqued our
interest there's been there's been
outrage in San Francisco over a
policeman shooting a man so there's the
question of police brutality we'll show
you the local affiliate clip outrage
over a cop shooting a man who was a man
who stabbed someone by the way he was in
the middle of stabbing that person
sources say the two men inside that
Subway's had been arguing over a
sandwich man who was staff was taken to
a course the other luminary nearby
residents like sherry Pittman were
outraged by the shooting so we have a
fight we're gonna get shot and I fight
all the time didn't ask for her lawyer
they may avoid this you how about knots
like you have the right to remain I go
beside out in the crime I told you I
don't stole it all the time listen it's
not because she's black it's because
she's hilarious notice the black officer
didn't laugh at that but she's funny she
is funny she's like a walking cartoon
character and I just they're outraged
over a cop stopping so in the middle of
a stabbing this is where you cannot find
middle ground don't it's like if you're
against reporting illegal aliens were
committing felonies or we're not going
to find common ground on the the anchor
baby issue so this of course this event
the police brutality apparently
quote-unquote has led to protests in San
Francisco protests riots signs where
they ultimately coined the new slogan
hands up let me stab you repeatedly
[Laughter]
and the first arrival paramedics were
actually reported as saying that it was
it was really a gruesome scene there was
blood everywhere it took a long time to
get it out of their clothes but they
finally did it still no luck in removing
the smell of subway leather on those
places no I know and then that Folsom
Street for a bunch of you're walking in
and the leather chaps I think I want a
Subway sandwich what do you wear leather
have added Dayton was years and that was
someone can explain to me there's like
what do you want south mistakes it ok
what do you want all right you know give
me the normal stake one what do you want
on it what makes it Southwest the
peppers what the federal wall do you
want the title rights a lot of flack to
Stephen Colbert made a a joke will talk
about this with Clavin later on where he
referred to Trump's mouth I'm sorry [ __ ]
holster for Vladimir Putin by the way I
think it's kind of a funny word so some
people are really outraged I don't tend
to get outraged but I didn't you know
they were talking about a boycott with
Colbert I didn't see any genuine
conservatives who I knew calling for a
boycott it seems like a little bit of
straw men allure because I see people
saying oh if you have problem with
Colbert's lewd comments on this but had
no problem with Trump's lewd comments
about you know grab them you know you're
you're you're highly inconsistent I'm
like I don't think that's the argument I
think that everyone jumping on hashtag
if they're conservative they're like
alright I kind of hate it Colbert this
is a fun thing to do today right but
people who are really upset about it are
upset for the homophobia that's right we
saw that HuffPo post what have many to
write about it's we meet of the HuffPo
queer voices I look as a section we need
to stop making jokes about Trump and
Putin okay sweetheart let me explain to
you the definition of need because you
seem to be a little murky
we don't need to stop making gay jokes
you need to learn a definition of need
yes need means I really really want you
to stop making gay jokes but I love the
cannibal
them from the left and I think it is fun
Colbert thought they won't come for me
because my fans are the ones who go
after other people yeah hey yeah what
are you sad Jill why do we have fire gay
jokes off-limits is it only home like
white he's got to be straight jokes was
a funny joke I don't think Stephen
Colbert's hilarious I certainly think
he's funnier than Samantha bee and
Trevor Noah I've said that I thought he
was funnier in character but I know I
don't want to see a guy boycotted
especially listen his isn't ratings are
doing well so he deserves what he does
well he's a little little one over the
Trump stuff I think a sling she just
locked into it but I think the to his
credit he's not backing down from the
comment he said he's saying I'm sorry is
the Mabel overboard with crassness you
know maybe not FCC appropriate but to
his credit he's not backing down with
you which as for comedy sake it's
refreshing to see ya watch for him
tomorrow though to call for the
boycotting or banning of someone who
says something offensive or they say
like I said we're calling for the
banning but they just encourage this
sort of crap storm of a surf so okay
in other news bill this is something
that's been making the runs important
bill nighy do this whole gender-bender
thing you can shut off the did yell jerk
the gender-bender thing gender exists on
a spectrum he says we talked about this
earlier in the week
wrote about it a lot of credit calm now
there was a meme and making the rounds
an all right sort of meme that went
around this one where it talked about an
episode of Bill Nye in the 90s and it
said gender is determined by your
chromosomes so a couple of things here I
interpreted this as a mean 9 there are
no quotation it's not a direct quote in
other words when I first saw this I saw
it as oh that must have been the
sentiment expressed yeah we did a lot
with music just to capture the sentiment
of Frank yeah something somebody
believes there's someone now kind of
understands memes okay so that that's
the case now we didn't run it on the
site because all of the leftist news
sites and we tend to read leftist news
sites more to check our sources yes
because we want to know what the left is
saying they said that it was completely
fake so places like Gizmodo in the
fact-checking website so this is
entirely fake bill nye never made this
quote he never said anything about
gender and chromosomes as a matter of
fact to prove their point and they
fooled us they should have less we
thought well maybe this is just another
hoax kind of like the Donald Trump quote
mean that goes around they fooled us by
including a clip of the Bill Nye episode
our genes are stored in parts of
ourselves called chromosomes they look
like this
chromosomes contain all of the genetic
information all the instructions you
need to make a person so when you watch
that you think well that seems dishonest
what's them because he didn't say
anything about about gender being binary
no turns out okay when these people said
fake news the implication that Bill Nye
had a show that said well Bill and I
didn't say it directly so I will allow
that clarify that but that same episode
that show included one of his female
cohorts on the show talking about two
genders you have a one and two chance
your gender being determined by
chromosomes that and here's the thing it
was in the same show after that clip and
it was edited out retro actively it was
censored by I think Netflix and or
Disney here's the clip they omitted I'm
a girl
could it just as easily been a boy
though because the probability of
becoming a girl is always one in to see
inside each of ourselves are these
things called chromosomes and they
control whether we become a boy or a
girl
one two not one in 73 not one in
pansexual gender fluidity
now usually if Gizmodo and if these
sites PolitiFact if they'd written
listen this meme is going around it's a
false quote bill nine did not say this
however in the episode it is in the
episode that was retro actively edited
to omit this clip they did say that
gender was determined by chromosomes and
highly implied that gender was binary if
they'd have written that it would have
been honest now we've written for
example about global warming about
scientists from NASA who said we're
going into a global cooling period and
in the articles and on this show it's
not by the way these same scientists say
but totally don't worry you guys because
global warming is going to occur after
those fifty years we provide that
context and the link these real news
sites calling out fake news sites turns
out were in cahoots were in on the gag
of the show being retro actively edited
do you any idea how how insanely
dangerous that is and something even
scarier you want to talk about Orwellian
people use the term so often it's it's
it's lost all meaning google has
recently issued their their guidelines
they said their algorithms are going to
favor real news over fake news and
they've actually named some
the sites that ran this story claiming
that people on the right relations so if
you look at their descriptions sites
like ours which I encourage you to
bookmark laden with brighter calm would
be considered fake news Gizmodo
politifact snows would be considered
real news by the way also university
publications like Berkeley today who are
hosting actual communists teaching
courses will teach start giving seminars
on how to eradicate Trump voters from
campus they band Milo the band and
Coulter but they're hosting communists
and his mother does this and Google's
going to favor them it has real news
something else that I think is even
crazy ok they went back even crazier
sorry my words I don't know stroke maybe
words have meaning it was a Stephen
Hawking dance I did it's coming back to
bite me something is even crazier they
went back and they edited a science show
now that it wasn't in addendum to
correct the science they didn't edit it
out because the science was inaccurate
they edited out the science from a
science show because it was offensive is
that not terrifying and this is again
the far left the Bill Nyes of the world
because motos of the world the fact
check towards the world these places who
consider themselves the arbiters of
truth are removing science because it is
offensive there's no excuse for that at
least when Al Gore did it was an
inconvenient truth he was going back to
correct some inaccuracies made a lot of
predictions there is a faster buildup of
heat here at the North Pole in the
Arctic Ocean and the Arctic generally
than anywhere else on the planet that's
not good for creatures like polar bears
who depend on the ice or in fact they
could just as easily float because
that's what polar bears do in water also
there could be three times the
population of polar bears ten years from
the film we don't know I appreciate the
Algor that's good
little-known fact he recorded that
voiceover from a Swedish masseuse doing
something with the arches of their feet
so uh health care bill let's get into
the health
what's happening what Judean hey dude
where were you
where was that wedding he will not
divide us
New York was fun as hell so I went over
to I supposed to meet you at the UK why
are you you Dean now if that was just an
idea we were just floating that around
we didn't confirm that I went there I
waited for like a week I call you back
he's a nice guy but we've got a just
gotta clarify that Jared yes my bad
personal calls near time so the health
care bill have you been following this
yeah both you oh you saw that the boat
passed yeah yeah how many votes was it I
know his single digits it's 217 like to
love and are some like that double check
but so it's pretty close yeah so this is
the repeal and replace idea of the bill
there's there are a few controversies
here so I want to explain it without
getting you too bored
uh-huh and it's hard to get people who
are not bored we talk about multi
thousand page bills this bill includes
something called the Upton mandate now
it allows for a few things okay
it allows for a few things to occur but
the most controversial aspect of which
is it allows a waiver for States now
what is his waiver allow a lot for it
allows States to allow insurance
companies to charge more for people with
pre-existing conditions so I want to be
clear some people are going out and
saying this means that states will be
exempt from the pre-existing condition
stipulation they're not I wish they were
I really wish they were I don't know
there should be any federal mandate to
cover pre-existing conditions that's not
what it is what this waiver allows and
what has to occur is a state has to
prove that premiums or costs have gone
up a significant amount so the state can
apply for a waiver which allows the
state to allow insurance couple does a
new mic and has hit it excited that
allows the states to allow insurance
companies to charge more that's what it
is that's what has Nancy Pelosi misses
Voldemort with her panties whatever it
is I'm in a bunch depends no conscience
Trump care is this race essential health
benefit
such as maternity care prescription
drugs emerging stop such as nuts protect
one of my law Americans with
pre-existing medical conditions as bad
as Trump care was the first time around
you know it was dead it died it died
right here on the floor now it's come
back to life like a zombie
Rick Grimes a blow away with a Colt
Python I I just she says that and I'm
sitting there going like yes it's like
we've talked about with Gavin McGinnis
we're saying the exact same thing by the
way the waiver we'll get into the
economics why I think that's a at least
a step in the right direction I would
like to see a complete elimination of
all of these mandates but this is
nothing new and before we get to the
economics the political selective
outrage is what I find to be hilarious
here when Obamacare the Affordable Care
Act was first passed waivers were
allowed to yeah now who do you think the
main recipient of these waivers being
exempt from the mandates were it was
almost entirely blue entirely liberal
states and counties as a matter of fact
one of the biggest champions of
Obamacare Anthony Weiner himself got a
waiver for his district passed a bill to
know what's in it it's gonna be we need
this for America okay you first
[Music]
now here's here's the economics of this
okay and this is this is something to
wear again like Jimmy Kimmel they
attribute motive the left only cares I'm
sorry let's just be honest they only
care about the screw-ups about the
leeches about the non-contributing
zeroes to society okay they say well who
are uninsured what about I get it every
now and then someone has a pre-existing
condition that is not their fault I
understand it by the way there have
always been high-risk health insurance
pools for that yeah but they don't care
about the people who foot the bill it's
not that we don't care about sick people
it's that we care about the other
Americans who have seen over a 20
percent year-over-year rise projected to
be at least 25 percent in 2017 as far as
the premiums it's that we care about
those people
it's that we care about the families who
are now seeing an average deductible of
$12,000 6,000 for an individual which
was unheard of before this it's not that
we don't care about sick people it's
that we care about everybody else who
has to bear this burden the economics of
Obamacare have been horrible that's why
it's wildly unpopular okay that's why
Donald Trump one wall repealing
Obamacare Obamacare is unbelievably
unpopular and I don't know remember when
they're going to pass it they always
Union car insurance as an example for
the as though car insurance was a was a
great analogy for a federal mandate free
to purchase health insurance a couple of
things
car insurance goes state to state yeah
and the car insurance that you're
purchasing is designed to protect
somebody else it's to keep somebody else
safe not you liability right built into
the word yeah it's kind of you know the
bare minimum doesn't cover any but
you're screwed you barely have some help
some males you bet you screw right the
bare minimum is somebody else you could
hurt so I've never thought it was a
valid analogy the car insurance analogy
but let's use it here since they've
liked to use this for so long the car
insurance analogy well you have to buy
car insurance here's the thing you're
buying car insurance for someone else
whereas health insurance you are
uniquely buying for you you are
purchasing health insurance for yourself
there's a risk assessment pool
they say this is about
risk this is about what we can spend on
these costs it's a business that they
run you are spending this money entirely
on your own health yet you are actually
burdening the costs for everybody else's
screw-ups you are paying for what
everybody else does it's the opposite of
car insurance nobody would accept this
if it were the process for car insurance
we have to ask any accidents yes 6 6 to
fender benders one spin out to roadside
ditch rolls one of which I don't
remember because I was hammered and I
hit a pregnant woman okay good news sir
you've been approved
that'll be one thousand eight hundred
and ninety six dollars wait what no I'm
I'm a perfect driver I have a perfect
record
no brake here it says you have two duis
and rammed and expect no I didn't do any
of those things
so just don't accept all analogies they
don't always work bas Rutten coming up
next in the ninja Clavin
[Music]
whole-body pricks with steven crowder
and not gage summer is a great time to
barbecue with friends family or even
make a few new friends that's right but
there are a few things you'll need first
and outdoor charcoal grill your grill
brush and utensils plenty of charcoal
matches and a healthy dose of lighter to
build the perfect grill fire first build
a pyramid with your charcoal then douse
with a generous amount of flammable
lighter fluid
when you're ready use your magic
interesting fact about lighter fluid
it's the vapors itself not the liquid
that's highly flammable that's why it's
always paramount that you take the
problem
homebody pretty much with steven crowder
and not gay Jerry sponsored by mug all
right hopefully our next guest takes
that as a compliment
longtime fan can't believe we got this
program today he's also right now he's
out there he's a create he admitted this
when he was a kid he was just telling me
the o2 trainer to lung capacity trainer
hmm check that out but of course people
out there know him bring up his Twitter
not kid Jarrett there we go boss Ross I
can we get more of an answer you former
UFC champion working of Pancrase
champion current MMA commentator and
all-around extraordinary American you
know I'm from here comes the boom a lot
of people who aren't bas Rutten thank
you sir it's weird when you think of
like the hundreds of thousands of people
who are gonna be watching and listening
to this and if you just put them in a
room you know it'd make you really
nervous like well that's a huge you know
it would be three four stadiums but you
don't really think of it when it's out
in the internet but they're all watching
right now going who is this path routing
guy yeah wait a minute is that route cur
or Kevin can wait yeah that could be in
places neighbor yeah what you now did
you forgive me did you go bald at a
young age cuz you shaved your head
really young so I just figured it was a
style statement yeah no I was just got I
believe it or not I used to be a model I
have modeling pictures you're gonna
laugh so hard but it was at the time
when they went from the from the
feminine Guy show to say yeah it's
crossed over to the real guys and that
at that time I came in the model agency
was owned by three women who loved me
and they put me out on a lot of work so
I have a lot of pictures hilarious
pictures all sold blue steel and so you
know they're those kind of pictures but
I was always doing my hair but not with
gel and all that stuff and a blow-dryer
never did that but one day I could have
fixed my hair and it could and I grabbed
him gel and I put gel in it and already
I thought that was a complete loosen
thing to do but I'm doing it
so I'm grabbing a blow-dryer and I'm
click the thing on and I'm looking at
myself in the mirror with a purple
blow-dryer this is so wrong it's like we
did that walked out my girlfriend in
time goes what are you gonna do I said
I'm gonna shave my head so she goes yeah
right I just went straight out went to
the barber I say shave it off really
[ __ ] complete bolt and it was the
biggest freedom
I received right off there is insane go
with the shower you just do this
that's washing your hair you jump in the
pool you come out that's drying your
hair it goes really fast you love it
that's why I can imagine and you also
don't have to worry about the point like
am I going bald am I losing my cousin at
that point no one cares we have the head
that can pull it off you know some
people who do it they just look like an
escaped mental patient who just climbed
down a rope of bedsheets and you know
ran out I was getting the remote pillow
pulled from the womb with with forceps
so that just would never work gosh okay
so bossless and everyone knows you from
from fighting and common table if they
follow your Twitter they know that
you're a pretty sharp guy I don't know
if you remember this so you're from
Holland right so I remember I assumed
assumed everyone who I knew raised in
Montreal like from Holland were just
super hippies who just wanted some a pop
all the time there was a picture of you
I think when you became an American
citizen you probably don't remember this
at the Lincoln Memorial giving the
finger when you and it said said like
this is for the terrorists this was
after 9/11 I don't remember that but
we're sitting there like okay bas Rutten
might be coming from a different angle
here might this was on myspace of all
places you're not oh you know I remember
because it was a big chair that I saw
somewhere and believe in Santa Barbara
and behind that beachy I was a wall and
was a paint in American flag the entire
wall Oh huge and I got to make a picture
here so I put on a crazy suit like a 70
student jump in the chair and you know
I'm sitting there flipping off and it
says freedom of speech and then it goes
after but you were the Lincoln you were
the one in the chair that's what it was
and ever reading about it in like I
think it was back then
ultimate grappling magazine you know and
like some people thought it was
controversial so you became an American
citizen listen as you know and in Europe
freedom of speech we see that now it's
not necessarily even Herrin like
European value that sort of rugged into
the I come from Canada where it doesn't
exist you can be jailed for hate speech
talking about that that flag with
freedom of speech
you've talked too much about how you
love the United States you become a
citizen you're kind of an anomaly why is
that you're different from a lot of
people who come over from from from
Europe or a lot of them go back you know
I don't know I think one of the people
is the problem many times you talk to
people in from Europe but they never
been to America now and if it never been
to America they just were people other
people saying they think this is a crazy
country you know my mom and dad for
instance they they didn't want to come
to first year visit us because they were
afraid to come at it for people shooting
each other on the street it wasn't it
was the most insane thing they have a
whole different picture of America when
I tell them hey did you ever go to
America
no I said why don't you go first and
check it out like my mom and dad they
came for only seven days the first time
the next time they came two and a half
months they rented an RV in Seattle they
went throughout all America saw
everything from America it's their
favorite country now they had no clue
why to propaganda or whatever it is you
know what they show about America on
European TV it's a different kind of
America I think so
yeah I'm why will people would be afraid
it's a great country well I remember
that too when I was raised in Canada
everyone's thought that you know people
in Texas they were run around with
cowboy hats and guns now a lot of people
do have guns that is true but they're
not shooting each other I actually as
when I moved to the city it was actually
pretty cool you have a lot of people
with guns who are law-abiding citizens
whereas we were sitting ducks in Canada
in Montreal actually we basically
invented the school shooting we had like
four in the decade of the nineties or is
literally it was just and there's
nothing anyone could do so it totally
changed what are you about saying I
should say every Canadian I've ever
known from like school and everything
the first thing they do they get here
they go to visit you know New York City
then they find someone to marry so they
could stay here almost everyone I've
ever met from college that's what they
do yeah yeah I I can imagine so what was
that process like to what do you
remember the moment where you said you
know what I want to become a citizen in
the United States
simple because our youngest daughter was
born here 2001 as soon as she was born
here I say okay she is America we're all
gonna become America now you know and
and then
my family can have dual citizenship at
the head of the household apparently
cannot and I said now I'm an American
you know my daughter's born here The
Four Musketeers right what's wrong all
for one right so that's what we're
that's what we did we became citizen and
you know it I believe that if you live
in the country you know you you should
become citizen I mean and live by the
rules of this country this is a very
important thing too because in Houston
you know sometimes people from other
countries come and they commit horrible
crimes and then in court they gotta go
yeah but you know what in their country
it's not fancy if you look at the road
giving do it and they go up they get
free because in their country and I say
yeah but you not don't live in that
country when I tried to pull that stunt
not gonna happen
everybody's so happy you know we love
you that we understand okay you go boom
you know it happens only a misdemeanor
in Saudi Arabia I think we like to play
by that well okay so this is only
because now I said don't get you started
but we got you started you did you
always think this way or did you have
kind of you know they call it like red
pill moment of clarity being in the
United States and enjoying some freedoms
and I say this as a Canadian I came here
and it was it's almost like in the air
you're like wow I'm just more free here
in Canada everyone was offended by
something you would say people were
constantly being jailed or being hauled
off because I said the wrong thing or
did the wrong thing
did you always think this way like
you're talking now or did it happen at a
specific moment or was it just a
transition living here it was just a
transition I I have a drawing that I
made when I was six years old about no
guida bird who flew to America so
America's always been in my mind I had
American cars at a Buick a Dodge pickup
trumpet two big tires you know you're
young you know do all these crazy things
I was always really probably always
really wanted to go to America I love
the American movies that's where all my
you know all the things that I use when
people came or when people asked me so
how do you speak English I first of all
everybody speak all in English in
Holland because you have to it's a
little tiny country otherwise nobody can
understand you well we see the American
movies with the Dutch subtitles so it's
much easier for us to understand that
once you start you know learning all the
lines but watching when you watch movies
like Scarface and you know you you think
the F bomb gets dropped
everywhere all the time here on the
street as well so when I came here and
my my first thing was I thought it was
freedom of speech here there's no speech
if I cannot say that yeah right so
that's what I thought first and with the
guns I you know I already did that then
that I I'd opened that and the reason
for this is one of the reasons that the
Japanese all the way back didn't attack
the mainland was because they knew they
were going to have a way every every
citizen is going to be a soldier
yeah so now you're not only fighting the
military you fighting 80% of the people
who have guns at home yeah you know so
that's that's a big army just suddenly
but that's why they didn't attack the
mainland and they started over there
well same with Switzerland even when you
look at Nazi Germany like gosh a
mountainous terrain and you know
everyone there has has a gun so there
let's just let's skip over and let's do
Poland first let me ask you this so
because a lot of people talk about the
sneaky one thing I'm a big fan of with
you is you know you're funny obviously
and it actually will should check out
your sketch comedy it's it's rare if you
never endorse sketch comedy I would say
not all of it works but some of it is
really funny which from a fighter is a
huge ringing endorsement it is really
funny stuff but you're a UFC champion
okay so there are a lot of you out there
who BS and like well if you need a gun
you're a coward I would just do this and
I got Tiger Claw and I don't need the
gun to feel secure your UFC your UFC
champion world renowned martial artist
well I don't want to ask you personally
if you carry because you know let's keep
that a surprise but what's your view on
that would you
chalk it up to I don't need to be
personally armed because I'm a martial
artist or or do you think people should
be regardless I think if you're
professional fighter you should you
should make sure that your arms because
the people on the street if they know
you they're not going to fight you
without a weapon right so if somebody's
gonna pull something yeah yeah I think
you should be prepared for that at least
at home and everywhere you know it's
it's a it's a dangerous thing out there
yeah probably normal person I can
understand you know maybe you know I
will be as much but you know as being a
fighter
yeah yes they're never gonna fight you
without a weapon so if something breaks
out they recognized me it's it's gonna
be big probably yeah that's a good point
and I've talked you know it's a lot of
fighters like listen the last thing I
that what you just said they're not
going to try and fight you fairly and be
it's a lawsuit waiting to happen
because if I'm a fighter it's national
headlines but even that's just you know
you read the message boards and you see
that attack from sort of the American
left today you know like well the gun is
just for see you're so insecure you
cling to you don't train one time we
oughta go it's very simple the bad guys
have guns I want to be ready when a bad
guy comes in you can it happen in my
life yes it can't happen it happens all
around me friends it happen people say
oh that whatever happened to me ask the
people that had happened to because
those people will say I always said it
never happens to me and it happened to
me yeah will happen you know and if it
happens why not being prepared while it
give the power to some criminals yeah to
defend yourself so that's the dumbest
comment there is you know there's so
many people there are really bad apples
in between and if they come I rather be
prepared and if you say though this is
this great line in the true romance with
Christian Slater one of my favorite
movies and he says the one thing I
realized over the last week is the
better it's better to have a gun and
don't need it than to need a gun and
don't have it yeah and the thing I'm
trying to make here that's no that's
absolutely true and I just think it's
great to come from a fighter because
that's sort of debunks a lot of these a
lot of these folks so what remember Jay
was what we had to the boss Burton would
find it funny where we went I think you
went to get your gun class guy who
everything about gun firearm instruction
no but then he's also like by the way I
also teach martial arts needs like a
sixth Don black belt yeah Hika Chi
jujitsu domain like thing like you're
certified to give you gun training but I
don't think the guy with the potbelly
and the homemade belt is necessarily who
I want teaching hand-to-hand combat
there's just a lot of BS across the
board right now and it's easy to sell
that to folks especially when you just
tell them you know they need to be
afraid of something so I'm the guy to
fix it but it's this is this is the
world you live in if you say to a guy
how big is your penis oh it's only six
inch tall oh you have a micropenis
everybody starts buying those pills you
have to say they're so easy to influence
you go like oh maybe I should look up a
chart with the average sized penises
before you know I mean people
you know you just give him a little
bully but I wouldn't use the word tall
in inches I'd say long tall as he's dead
and ridges it's a straight text
translation that I do but I tell the guy
oh he's big you know what that means
he's tall but here it means something
now do they speak French in Holland I
don't know no this is that's Belgium
right just - yeah Dutch and then at the
border where I used to live it's the
Belgium Flemish German okay so a lot of
people and from that area the lower part
of hallo speak German as well yeah also
known as freaky-deaky touch I learned
three key touch yeah I didn't know I
didn't know this but I know it because
it sounds similar to a french-canadian
accent a little bit with boss I noticed
that you know kinda if you hear like my
mom it's not what people here were used
to a German accent you know and then you
think when you think Dutch people would
assume it sounds more like like Sven
computer but it sounds more frightening
to me I don't know I think it wasn't
Michigan to me there's so many Dutch
people there that yeah I've heard a
little bit the Dutch people are cheap no
that's the weirdest thing I never got
that you know they say let's go dutch on
a date and I never in my life
experienced ever the guy over space I
don't know where it comes from
also what I when I came here and all the
Dutch and people saying with cheapened
my first party that I went to from from
a guy guy it says hey Kate when you want
to come to the party come to the party
by by the presence I come to give him
the present I won't go to the bar get it
get up here and the guy go I said
there's six dollars excuse me
and he says six dollars I said no no I'm
with the party here the birthday party
he says it's six dollars and you guys
talk about touch people and they will
pay for it because it's their birthday
nobody pays the thing so I go like wow I
can I can make parties now I can
actually make money you know I own the
worst day and I tell the people what is
your worst day it's a Wednesday I'm
gonna do a party next Wednesday I want
20% is a good thing this question that
do you do are you not see about turning
the lights off when you leave the room
we're in my living room the turn are you
our Nazi about turning them off because
that's what do I know
they're not it has a different
connotation for a Dutchman are you Marty
know what I started doing like if I walk
through the house and she lied on I
actually turn it off I started lately
started doing that yeah but normally I
yeah yeah I don't like a lot of light
okay the lights I mean why wouldn't you
what is that question
Oh in Michigan that was one thing I
noticed everyone every Dutch person
there is just just adamant about making
sure every light is off on every room
you're not using all the time always
I've never heard that yeah they're
really cheap there that's always
something they the unplug the
refrigerator tonight so maybe that's
just an American thing maybe
the refrigerator thing well that was a
joke I did see people coffee filters
washing coffee filters but I seen this
in America as well we would make
horrible detectives we've gotten a root
of nothing here coffee filters okay so
so boss would have a ton of time but man
I hope to have you academically here
this this story and people who come here
and and and how their views change and
they become Americans let me ask you
this kind of finally because how long
have you been in the United States now
how long have you been a citizen
actually tomorrow 20 years Wow
congratulations my oh it's liberation
day from Holland the day we got married
is the day our dog dog was born it's
it's a great it's the day we we met each
other my wife and I twenty five years
ago so yeah we married for 20 years
we're together 25 years 25 years MIT so
must be quite the catch to a nail down
LWOP oh because he was uh he was known
to be quite - yeah that time in my
fighting time I was a little crazy guy
yeah so you know she's the same let me
tell you that she'll go straight to
heaven that one she's amazing that's
rare though for someone in a high
profile you know obviously well you're
in California and in the entertainment
estreet it's rare for someone to be
married that long and I don't know what
it's like in Europe but in in French
Canada people generally don't get
married they just sort of cohabitate
so that was a distinct as a matter of
fact in in Canada and Quebec I'm sure
you've been there because there's a lot
of it's huge MMA area if you see a
wedding ring almost guaranteed
Anglophone in Canada French Canadians
don't get married and most of my
European friends either don't get
married who have known or they get
married later but it seems like that's a
typical certainly the entertainment
industry in and maybe Europe what I mean
25 years what is that just something you
always knew you wanted to be with one
person and just made it work no she's
just perfect for me I mean everything is
there you know it's it's weird it's I
don't I think at least like ten eleven
years there's no fighting in this house
there's no screaming in this house
there's no words and there are Zoey
that simply won't happen everywhere that
we say hey no no that will be as loud as
all my friends they asked if she assists
they make her in a laboratory what
happened but something happened I was in
contact and suddenly well okay here's
another thing I'm sorry but is a
cultural difference oh you say you know
you say God every person I've known from
from from Deutschland
you know distinctly kind of unchurched
distinctly more agnostic atheist like
it's not a super here obviously sort of
it you have a way more it's not a
secretly given but we Mormon evangelical
Christian community so were you raised
that way or is that something you came
to in the States
I kept doing the stage I was raised that
way till I was 12 years old then it
stopped and then I got distracted
because that's where all the atheist
started coming in but knowing it better
with the books and my mom and dad they
start actually believing that be as and
you know so slowly but surely you know
that happens and you don't go to church
anymore that five years ago about five
years ago I was just sitting in on the
conference about about life not even
blog just about life and the way he was
explaining that it's a very smart guy
too large in Leo Severino that was just
I was like that was it was so much that
felt together for me ago this is crazy
now at the center was also in the world
renowned doctor father a burger who's an
exorcist
straight with the Vatican who does the
worst cases yeah
of course there was the Navy SEAL team
16-member for me under the priest a guy
so I wanted to talk to him yeah that's
the story issue here you go crazy now
you have to understand I had a run-in
with a ghost in my house and the bad
spirits and and that's why also for me
it's easier to correlate because people
got oh you're making that up
no no and it's not making up if it
happens 25 times you know it's really it
was really heavy it's really pushed me
in the band really it was really
attacking me until the final day I just
at 3 o'clock in the middle of the night
you know you what I did the opposite the
foot Jesus passed away at 3 so 3 o'clock
at night they says the most activity and
that's where I went out of the spots
where always where it appeared and I
just challenged it for an hour and it
stopped after we saw the curtains we saw
somebody running through the court with
my entire family
curtains flying up to the ceiling not
like somebody to the ceiling I was 100%
certain there was somebody in the house
yeah rents the other side but nobody was
in the house everything was locked doors
were locked windows will lock and even
if the windows rope and I mean the
carpet it flew up against the ceiling so
there was a lost privity and and I heard
about these near-death experience people
who go away and we see other things in
the room next door we know exactly in
the next door what the people were
saying there Hey my father was smoking
he never smoked so they come back and
they say why were you smoked you how do
you know well I actually was floating
above you guys and I heard the whole
conversation so I know 100% there is
something I refused to believe there is
not something after this life this is
just a test where all this you know
everything there is without time and
space here there's the only place where
we have time so I truly believe this is
just a race
it's just eration I got good we have
some listeners coming to read bathroo
now I coming from the Joe Rogan podcast
was saying I haven't spoke enough pot
yet for this conversation
before it but that's fascinating my
closest near-death experience now pales
in comparison I was getting turned over
in a kayak and I thought I was going to
talk I cause I couldn't get out that was
it I don't have you ever been a Calle
like an old kayak but it's impossible to
get out unless you know how to flip back
over and I thought I was going to die
that's about it that's my near-death
experience really is interesting yeah I
had one oh fascinated with
bring you back we can talk about so much
more too we have Andrew Clavin we have
Andrew Clavin coming up Andrew :
and your Clavin coming up so uh boss
where's the best place for people to
find you you know I get an old guy I
guess right Facebook is where I have a
lot of activity on my Facebook account
on my Twitter password and Facebook is
just facebook.com slash password for
Twitter that's where I answer pretty
much all questions okay some people ask
me question box with an MMA and then on
Instagram that's when I show pictures
here and there but I'm not a big guy
into that for some reason I'm I'm
getting more into it but that's the
channel your inner male model again for
Instagram that's what you need to do
that's all it is it's just big card yeah
yeah there you go
I don't either podcast you're doing I
have a podcast together with Mauro
Ranallo actually gonna shoot it in like
a half an hour okay do it yeah it's
going to be released tomorrow it's a fun
podcast it's where we're going to talk
about cannabinoids we have it that
person we interview that person was
completely cured just using CBD oil yeah
and and a good diet do chemo didn't take
any pills didn't do anything
and it's completely stage four
completely cured so there's a lot of
power there I'm in a group called
athletes for care it's all about help
athletes professional athletes because
I'm talking about a lot of football
players who are on that board as well
yeah everybody go you know the vicodins
the pain pills it's such a it's such an
ugly drunk it's so addicting and say you
know and the CBD does the same thing
yeah it's not addictive so addicting so
I want people to be informed I'm gonna
do schools here I do the school talks
already for for kids who go to college
you know every year I talk for 500 kids
and I tell them what they can expect but
now it's going to be added the CBD thing
is gonna be a time guys you know because
once it starts there it's a scary
documentary it goes from oxycontin to
heroin because it's cheaper to use
heroin and yeah
I've seen that and we are comic on here
too already lying who ran to that
problem so it's a matter of fact he was
actually advised to he's open about it
so I'm not adding what he was advised to
use heroin because you know since it was
directly injected bypasses the liver so
we're told like it's actually if you're
taking all these pills it's better to
take the heroin but bas Rutten Elwha fo
which means the handsome
so now you see why and seeing it as
webcam thank you so much sir we have to
go but we have to have you back soon to
talk more about everything yeah there we
can now if you want to dive into
something deeper than that we have the
time for that probably not that we don't
mean it's something deeper look at him
leaving insulting right before we have
that we have music playing there's music
I don't I hear what's happening
[Music]
tell me
hello people watching this for free now
some of you are members of the mo club
and some of you are cheapskates
a lot of credit accomplished Month Club
we've talked about this that's where you
get daily crowded we're going to be
offering it for free on YouTube at some
point here the next month I don't know
exactly when because I have to travel
but it's 99 dollars annually 69 dollars
for students that's you know you get
access to the whole CR T V library and
we are adding some really cool names
right now you know it takes takes a
month or two for these things to be
announced but I'm excited and you start
trying vain talking about it it is
training there's going to be an ongoing
series Mudd Club is truly it with the
amount of people who joined in uprising
it is it is a way we've talked about
voting with your dollar there are a few
ways to sort of sort of stamp okay so
what I believe when you join them up
when you join see our TV it is a stamp
you're putting that money out there with
no real physical expectation of
something in return although great
content listen you do get the show deal
and you get it now audio downloadable on
the go is that starting next week next
week it will start this week but that no
it's a glitch at the platform change but
it's what allows us to continue
uploading so much more content to
YouTube we never wanted to do a
bait-and-switch and give you and then
pull it away and so you have to pay for
it I don't know if you've noticed but
since Mudd Club we've been providing
more free content than ever
here's the thing we've been providing
more free content than ever and the free
content is generating less revenue than
ever because of like we talked about
Google's algorithms and fake news they
don't like what we're doing they don't
like what you're doing and the only way
we can continue to do this and create an
alliance with more people and grow right
now we're doing a daily show not get
Jared when you join my club you get his
show with Courtney on Fridays morning
grinders but the only we can grow truly
for unplug us and create a whole network
and right now we have a dozen people
employed just a little under the ladder
with credit umbrella is if you join that
money ironically supports all the free
content and why is it why is it free
content important free content it's good
you know they're kind of business models
and you see this out there with a lot of
conservatives for example Fox News their
only goal is to preach to the choir
that's most conservative networks out
there right as a matter of fact every
word I've ever worked where they were
conservatives they're saying we want
less on you do we want less free content
we want to get them to pay the
difference we'll see right to you why
they're so great and with with what we
do with mug Club is because listen yeah
you want to behind the paywall we can
talk about Allah
things it's more conversational because
we know you guys we know the Mudd Club
members we're close we tweet we often
direct message sometimes we take live
tweets but it's so important to still
reach new people I mean today it may
sound silly but you know you can see
hundreds of thousands of peanut millions
upon millions of people each month
hearing new things whether it's about
the health care mandate if it's as
simple as someone saying I had no idea
that the Affordable Care Act increase
premiums it could be something as simple
as someone saying I had no idea that
chromosomes had anything to do with
gender people are learning new things
all the time so the free content is
important that's the mission is to
inform and hopefully educate people but
the only way to do that is through the
premium content the premium content the
paid content is what allows the free
content to bring more people into our
camp and change the political cultural
landscape of the country so a lot of
credit a calm slash mug club we
appreciate it don't be cheap
[Music]
all right glad to have our next guest
always love him on the program but the
problem is we always talk before the
program that's true then we're sitting
like this is the show we'll talk during
the commercial break and it'll make some
point so you know him you follow him at
Andrew Clavin on the Twitter he has a
fantastic book out the great good thing
you could read it on Amazon read on it
even ordered an Amazon nobody reads on
it's like Stephen Colbert trying to
understand social mean you can read it
on the books of the faces Martin I cool
kid the HIPAA ruse and he just recently
spoke at but Andrew Clavin show I would
say Daly wired good friends of Daly wire
just recently spoke at Oberlin College
there right Andrew Clement I did I did I
was a smash hit with people trying to
smash me and hit me it's a no actually
with you I would imagine as a
conservative you're somewhat used to
being heckled you know I'm really not I
have to be honest with you they all that
happens like a heckled and at the same
time John Coulter was being attacked and
yeah I was like threat well so I felt
kind of like I felt it was pretty mild
but I will say that normally I'm invited
to speak in front of conservatives and
it didn't really even occur to me until
the last minute that I was walking onto
the most liberal one of the most liberal
of colleges in the country and that
people might be upset to have me there
but I still have this kind of innocence
of thinking like oh but I'm such a nice
fellow why would anybody there's a scene
there's a scene in the novel war and
peace where this young Russian soldier
sees the French charging over the hill
and he says they want to kill me me whom
everyone loves not like I've read war
and peace and it doesn't just occupy
space on my bookshelf as a gun case
don't worry nobody thinks you bring up I
want to go back to Overland but they're
sure I have not read war and peace I
won't live not read word because I've
covered the page of it and when I went
to college we didn't read Mark Twain we
didn't read any of the American classics
none of it we'd read like tears of a
tiger and all the social justice crap
especially in Canada even back then I
was reading about you sure this is
really what I should be reading in
English literature but there are a lot
of things like I was sitting there
thinking about
the Korean War you know I know a tunnel
I know very little about the Korean War
I know I know old like bastards who get
mad when I'm in Korea but I've studied
Vietnam but I don't know the ins and
outs of the Korean War and it's
dangerous to say that on this program
because someone will then try and quiz
me next on the Korean War but there are
a lot of things were saying you know
what I thought that way about the the
First World War I'm like everyone talks
to the Second World War gets so much
attention and I know it's not
complicated the Germans are [ __ ] oh
yeah that's not it
the First World War see the thing is you
know I lived overseas for a long time
the First World War wiped out a
generation of men so over there you know
in Europe it's huge in the same way like
every little village in America has a
civil war monument on the East Coast
yeah every every tiny village lost like
you know a thousand guys in World War
one when I was there I read seriously
this is absolutely true I read at least
20 books about World War one and when it
was over when I was finished I still
didn't know why it had started Germans
being Germans I'd say they're always a
problem it was kind of like it was kind
of like Europe was saying you know
things are going so well let's kill
everyone you know let's commit suicide
it was it was the end of the Europeans
apparently Kim Jong Un's and written the
same books and getting ideas okay here's
the thing here's the thing most of the
people I would say in a room I don't
know 50 let's guess 50 people I'm not
very good at that but let's say 50
people in that room I would say 40 to 50
percent of them were left-wing kids and
they were polite they were charming they
got up afterwards and asked me questions
and yeah you know it was great we had a
really interesting exchange I was really
interested in talking to them yeah three
or four of these people were rude nasty
little people and two of them I swear
needed psychiatric care yeah I mean one
of one of them was like obviously he had
some kind of gender dysphoria [ __ ]
yeah it was bizarre and like and comes
in and puts his feet up on the chair and
like throws is like you know it is
sleeveless arm open
all the stuff so I'm looking up his
armpit and I just thought you know you
think people hate you because you're gay
they hate you because you're allowed
past yeah that that transgender on
campus who did you see that where the
guy who did you see that the transgender
at Berkeley just freaked out in the guy
where he they were let's trick this
person we still don't know if it's male
350 orange hairy town orange hair
crumpling up a trump flag and guy goes
oh what a big man you are because I've
shut your mouth I'm an effing woman and
it's clear that God wasn't trying to
troll the [ __ ] because the guys
response is just a call from the Dean
and that's what we talk it's a it's a
subspecies they actually don't have a
lot in common with your run-of-the-mill
[ __ ] you know your rube halls the
people who just kind of want to be
[ __ ] in that section of the bar with
the cool kids this is the whole
subspecies of gender fluids and
sexuality it really only exists on
campus and you know the terrible thing
about it is is I'm sorry but a lot of it
is mental illness and to tell a guy with
the mental eyes this is what I came away
with this is what I came with these
university left us I mean it's mean it
doesn't mean to tell a guy with a
problem that his problem is society
instead of you know his mind
you know I nothing that society does for
this guy is gonna make him any happier
and to tell him that if he can just get
everyone to agree that he's a woman
poof he'll be a woman you know I mean
ain't gonna happen and that he might be
a poof but I don't think they're like
the muppet guys are gonna show up right
you're just so crazy like it's probably
a handful out of even the 40 or 50
percent of the students who are who are
left so the rest of them are right half
of them let's say left let's just do it
for easy numbers numbers am 50 percent
conservative 50 percent left and you
know single-digit percentage points of
these kids
were left but the faculty acquiesce to
them the late-night shows acquiesced to
them the Democratic national platform
acquiesced in the women's March aqueous
system these people represent point zero
zero one percent of population earth but
they occupy such a huge portion of the
American cultural spectrum
I just got imagine people are seeing it
well and also with you I mean it let's
let's get down to the fact that these
are kids you know these are these are
people whose you know your brain doesn't
even form fully until you're 25 years
old these are kids the professors and
the administration are in charge of them
and are their mentors they have an
Oberlin they have a black dorm they have
a dorm for black people
David dr. David you know you leave
college you grow up in a place where
everybody you know is black or Italian
or Irish or Jewish or whatever you know
me because you're supposed to meet all
these different people and realize oh I
hate these people let me go back home
yeah expand your mind instead they've
got these kids hiding away in their
little black dorm I mean Martin Luther
King would roll over in his grave
seriously I was thinking I was thinking
people in my generation walked unarmed
into the teeth of guns and clubs and
dogs to get you out of the situation and
you're so scared of being slighted
you're going back in yes it's it's the
same and and you know the telling them
that they're victims I was talking to
christina hoff sommers because she spoke
before me yeah a couple of months before
me and got protests and all that and she
said that the women were going into
their safe spaces because they were
triggered because she told them they
weren't victims they weren't oppressed
yes would trigger them here's the thing
I am
I'm with you and it is it is remarkable
though that these people have as much
poll as they do III mean again if you
read HuffPo salon AOL any of these
mainstream websites and we're not just
talking and not just on what leftist
websites either just any site that's not
right wing it's as though there's this
unwritten agreement like oh yeah she
yeah I couldn't find out who it was even
on campus reform a conservative site
this 300-pound person with orange hair
so I'm a woman you better respect they
described this person as transgender I
swear to you we had a 20-minute round
table or we're going to a hall a second
it looks like a man but saying he's a
woman is kind of you know like like just
lack of any muscle tissue so fat so it's
really hard to determine work so is this
a male to female transgender it's a
female to male transgender Jared just
said I still wouldn't put any money down
on it but I think lesbians you think a
big old strong in milk and none of us
because the article just act like this
is a transgender it's like well call in
a second this is key information we need
to know 300-pound orange haired mohawk
transit yeah exactly well exactly that's
a person who probably needs some help
you know and like yeah telling him
telling him that it you know his world
is terrible because you're in it you
know the world is a little more terms
you're in it but I mean it's particular
world is too it's just cruel it's a
cruel thing to do and I think it's cruel
it to make some of these conservative
kids
now you're leftist garbage or get a bad
grade you know that's a terrible thing
to do to a young person you know you
know I'm gonna teach you to have no
integrity I'm glad you've come to
Oberlin because when you come here we're
gonna teach you have no integrity
lie to get ahead and that's the life
lesson we give you you're right now
thank you so much I appreciate you see
most liberal campus in in the United
States and at that point you're talked
about the difference maybe like a single
percentage point like Oberlin and it's
like wow I don't know maybe if you go to
Cornell
maybe it's like 94 percent liberal as
opposed to maybe five at a certain point
it doesn't matter anymore but yeah it
really is this just horrible sort of
manifestation of the worst that humanity
has to offer and they're in this unholy
alliance with the media the
entertainment industry and academia and
it does not represent don't even
represent the left in the United States
like a lot of people who vote that's
right Clinton yeah I think that's right
I think it doesn't you know it
represents
I mean the left has this whole thing
about that that somehow speaking the
truth is unvirtuous they have this whole
idea that it's really really so much
better to say he's a woman because why
would you hurt his feelings and you'd go
like well the truth actually matters you
know the truth kind of sets it free and
establishes you know we can all talk
about the truth because we agree what it
is but they actually think that the
reality will change because they
describe it differently
you know that if you describe that sky
is when somehow they'll be healthier of
mind and happy and that's gonna take
away the fact that the inside his mind
he's going scream into your car he's not
gonna top of your lungs no and people
like Blair White on and Tarun Meyer and
people who are transgender who openly
talk about this not talked about it as
someone who actually has you know
struggle with we've talked like mental
health issues with ADHD which manifested
is like severe depression at one point
they thought all kinds of things are
wrong with me as a kid well imagine if
they just said oh you know what he's
just he's fine let him be that way and
they didn't actually try to help me I
would have never it's your fault for
calling him sad if you would just call
him happy then he'd be happy you know I
mean it's right so it's like somebody
with an eating disorder you're like yeah
you waste sixty pounds you look great no
you are a little fat you know when you
say you're a little fat
go ahead starve yourself and when you're
dead you will say you're alive and then
you'll be alive it's correct we talked
about that Lena Dunham lost weight and
she was and we hats off to her like you
know she looks better and she goes you
know what is this I did it for me not
for anybody else but I feel better I
sleep better and let me tell you
something people endorphins are real
we're sitting like yes whole time and
you lose just saying we're hate speakers
it's because we want what's good for you
really is just like a parent with a
child it's like listen don't put your
hand in a stove no don't put your hands
it's gonna hurt keeps burning and you
know I just wonder the hand is all
bandaged up like Liam Neeson and darkman
there finally say you know yeah we
didn't tell you that the whole time
that's and for Lena Lena Dunham now when
she takes her shirt off people won't
press the remote you know
they actually not stop water I wouldn't
go they might just go from 4k to
standard def tolerate that kind of
imagery yeah I at least I probably won't
have to scratch up my eyes that was my
usual reaction so I HBO girls like let's
just take him well that's not true Lena
Dunham was really the most unattractive
one on that show there's some other
girls who are attracted on that show
look II imagine she's like a swollen
thumb that was such a sexist things I'm
sorry I'm sorry
no gergan looks the same it's just it's
a genre of people Kyrgyz Karl Rove might
have done they could have been on that
MTV some show by steve-o okay so so this
happened and that was an eye-opener for
you we were talking about this you know
working in entertainment reliving out in
Los Angeles you know Jimmy Kimmel
obviously the news of this week and
what's happened with his son was
horrible and all when I first saw the
story I just saw the first segment we
was talking about his son it was very
touching and moving and you know look at
the modern miracle of medical innovation
in science but wow you know that that's
incredible glad his son's okay
I didn't see the second portion where it
goes by the way Trump sucks I was like
well hold on how do you get to that
pivot and and that happened and you were
talking about this earlier the stephen
colbert his comment on on donald trump
putin unbelievable yeah what was it for
because I don't want to what was his
attorney said about Donald Trump with
Putin what was the term busy he said he
said is the the only good thing about
Trump's mouth is just a [ __ ] holster for
Putin Vladimir Putin so the funny word
given that funny word but it's like you
know if that were if that were you
saying that suddenly the gays would be
outside your door you know like banging
on the door but you know because he's
anti Trump it's okay first of all the
guys the guy's not that funny I mean he
was kind of funny when he was imitating
Bill O'Reilly but he's not that funny
off the show and secondly if does every
single late-night comic have to be an
anti-trump on an anti Trump tirade every
night I mean isn't a little boy
and the you know the fact the fact that
people like Samantha be Samantha B and
Trevor Noah are like sucking comedy out
of the air like the world world was a
funnier place before they got there I
mean they have now it kind of makes your
cheeks cave-in like that's you it's anti
laughs it's like pre and post fall of
Skynet when I see them to turn the theme
songs on all here is done
would you look at cold there's ratings
his ratings are great it's something
Colbert's day I think it's blending
funny
I think Kimmel can be funny I don't
think samantha bee samantha bee and
Trevor Noah have never been entertaining
accidentally yes but why do they all
have to I mean is there I know you're
kind of funny I mean is there nobody
funny you were funny once it was through
a Thursday ever maybe not at one point
yeah I mean is there nobody that they
can find who at least would toe a
different lines so the people could
change channels and say oh that's a
funny pro-trump trope no I mean it's all
got to be the same thing you know and we
got we got so much flack yeah I think
the right claim a lot of the right they
claim they want it but they don't really
want it because you know we do the show
and it was just listen it's comedic goal
there was nothing but jokes about Bill
O'Reilly groping his interns and the
thing is it was so great for me cuz I
just stay silent this whole time and I
knew he did it Oh
joke joke joke joke joke I've been
writing this for so long like how do you
know we need to stick together I'm like
well who's we
he's not a conservative a and B and we
make fun of Trump we'll get it we're
going to make fun of ben Carson because
he's hysterical I think you're sweetest
guy alive and I think a lot of people
you know if you want to be the world's
most powerful genie and everything that
comes with it and they don't really want
that and the lie I think you're right I
think that's right yep knows it I think
the left is like just keep anything that
will offend us in a box put it away
whereas the right is it yeah bring on
the comedy and no one they get something
that bothers them they have an issue
with it and I just think it's just
harder to sort of get the right on one
page but I think not I think its
clickbait forward leftist I think flick
bait it just like it was Pro Shop Pro
Shop Pro Trump for all the right wing
websites leading up to the election all
the way through the primaries I think
it's just cheap comedy they know that
looking at look at Colbert's ratings
they're not bad right now they're
actually doing well I think it's it's
easy territory for them to
and I think that it just keep doing
what's working yeah that's what that's
that's right what happens is it's a it's
a vicious circle because as they lose
their right wing audience they're only
audience they can get as left-wing so
they double down and keep bringing them
in or else they they run out of audience
yeah no of course and you know Maureen
Dowd bless her heart has actually spoken
about this she said my audience does not
want to read during the election she
said my audience does not want to read
bad things about Hillary Clinton and
Dowd has always been very honest about
the Clintons she's one of the few people
on the Left who actually went after them
and she said you know they do not want
to hear it they don't want to hear so
you you open the New York Times now a
former newspaper you know and it is like
I mean it's it is like it's like walking
into a room of you know women after
they've seen a mouse flashing women it
is like people jumping on chairs
screaming you know where is it where is
it it was like stop drop right I mean
it's amazing and I think that that is a
problem on the right - I really do I
mean yeah yeah if you can't make jokes
about Bill O'Reilly's facing women
around the desk
after all we're conservatives we're
supposed to be nice to women you know
I've been looking into how much it would
cost to actually have a cuckoo clock
where instead of the pirate running out
chasing the beer made it's Bill O'Reilly
chasing Aziz P in this corner cuz that's
we call this interns the ones he fear
most were spinners go ahead Andrew did
work at Fox was it true that everybody
knew this was going on okay I can't
speak for everybody did I know yes and I
said and I came out right away when aunt
when the stuff came out with Sean
Hannity I said now listen and I know W
specil she's a crazy person I have no
evidence whatsoever it's not common
knowledge with Sean Hannity if it were
it would be a surprise and I ultimately
I put my I put my money on the line and
by the way we just saw another
personally Fox's if you go back and I
said listen they're going to be two more
people I guarantee you information is
going to come out about and one of them
will be directly affiliated I think with
Sean Hannity but and I think they're
gonna try and use that by proxy to hurt
Sean that's I I have no evidence the
matter of fact I have evidence to the
opposite when used to do is freedom
tours he was very careful just from an
intelligence standpoint to not be alone
with women who weren't his wife he would
often leave
he wouldn't stay at the same hotel as
other people's he's always struck me as
a very honorable guy he just seems like
a really straight arrow guy right no
gentleman but the difference is Bill
O'Reilly did it I think you know and I
can just say from what I've constantly
heard walking the halls at Fox you know
it was it was just an assumed truth and
several names that were outed one of
them I knew was a friend of mine I had
heard this before so it didn't come to
me as a surprise it doesn't mean that
everyone is guilty and I hate that
they're going to try to do this as a
headshot by proxy to everyone else right
right but yeah I think he'd yeah but you
know it is funny when I first went to
Fox I think was to be on the gutfeld
show yeah and I said to Greg you know
this is like bizarro high school because
it's all the nerdy guys with the most
beautiful women on earth you know and so
it's like it's like the opposite of high
school where they're you know nerdy guys
never gotten anywhere near those women
yeah that may have been a bad form you
get dates in high school we're suddenly
going look sunshine let's pair them with
a bunch of women on the leg cams and
convince them that it's not because they
have money what could possibly go wrong
I've had the worst recall today but I
remember I was going to talk about your
ton of these kids on Oberlin College
first thing I do is I say hey Google
good morning and it gives me the news of
the day the temperature and I have this
little Google home thing but I make sure
it's not listening when unplug it
anyways
conspiracy decide because Google's
they're always watching your lexer
Google they actually it's in the fine
print they can listen always it's a
learning computer so yes you have to
manually say google mute yourself or hey
Alexa stop listening otherwise it's
always listening it's written in the
pamphlet anyway I say hey Google and
it's playing news from NPR because
that's the default and there was some
kind of protest I don't know if I was
talking about mayday or what do I put
you back to sleep if there was someone
yelling you know it's on a college
campus it might have been Berkeley and
they were screwed I swear to you a bunch
of people chanting out we have nothing
to lose but our chains hold a second
your scholarship based on minorities
your job your master's degree in German
poetry that your parents a lot more to
lose than your chains this is like this
is like it Yale they're having this
symbolic hunger strike what's a symbolic
hunger strike is where you don't eat
until you're hungry and then you eat you
know
that is that's the left that is the
academic left in a nutshell though it's
like symbolic actions against symbolic
oppression that's not actually happening
you know
and it makes you a symbolic hero I took
symbolic actually and symbolically fail
to understand they're not to hero that
campus needs the symbol it deserves all
right Andrew Clavin where can people
best find you sir
today listen to the podcast on The Daily
wire and you can come and find me on
Twitter at Andrew clay at Andrew
claiming the Andrew Clavin show highly
recommend it also been Shapiro's over
there a good guy good guys guys we'll be
back a wonderful place to work it is oh
it's a wonderful place good people we
got to go we got it
whole-body bridge with steven crowder
and not gage here summer is a great time
to use the pool and cool off but it's
not for everyone I'm not a confident
swimmer and that's why there are a few
key safety tips you have to follow first
before you take part in your summer
refreshment the proper floatation
devices and a positive attitude go a
long way to ensuring a pleasant cool
experience and fencing off the danger
zones as a must to ensure that the
aquatic Lea challenged don't find their
way in I know how is that happiness but
we had the fence up that's not a real
fence that's another nice office good
wins way
whole body prick with steven crowder and
not gay jerry sponsored by mugs join
today and louder with brighter calm /
month
[Music]
[Music]
for some reason with the drowning dance
I always make it not kid your dies
that's a lot of work that drawing dance
so grateful bas Rutten Andrew Clavin
show went a little long today but I know
sometimes people sometimes people
complain that like Ice Show used to be
longer on Thursday well now we kind of
split the difference the daily shows for
those who remember members typically
about it's like a cable show it's like
around between 44 minutes to an hour and
then we add an extra guest for you on
the Thursdays by the way coming very
soon I don't know if it's going to be
the week after next week right now
there's a free trial from there's always
a free trial if you join the mug Club or
go to see our TV for seven days on the
site but we're going to be offering this
show for seven days for free maybe even
14 days I don't know I should read the
fine print on YouTube so for those who
still you know listen if you if you want
to support the show and you're tired of
YouTube's crap there you go we'll let
you try it even for free using YouTube
strength against itself you know some of
this earlier today and we were talking
about earlier in this show it just kind
of hit me I'm the left arenas modern
movement right self-esteem movement
which is funny because I think the
generation Z people buildings below
Millennials I think they're rejecting
that the whole culture of like no red
pens you're you're younger than I am and
you got it more than I did I'm kind of
at the top end of Millennials and we saw
it coming like ah these are cats you
know gosh they can't lose a soccer game
and then you came in and you're like a
soccer game so there's kind of that
middles that eye of the tornado of
Millennials who are on board with it did
you notice too numerous have eyes have
you figure that one out
that's a try no I'm in her well yet
tornadoes all your and you know in the
middle of the cyclone my guess saw its a
cyclone it's a tornado it's a vortex do
you know do you home out anyways
hurricane is the same thing just bigger
but um it's sort of been rejected by the
the generations either becoming more
conservative and I think they actually
want to get by on their merits and I
think the reason for it is this whole
modern self-esteem movement rings really
Hollow ya know people need to have good
self-esteem everyone should feel good
about themselves no everyone should have
a good body image incorrect not
everybody should have a good body image
not everybody should feel good about
themselves we never used to have
self-esteem movements because
self-esteem was earned
if you accomplished crap you had good
self-esteem
and if you didn't you had horrible
self-esteem and deservedly so that's
what it used to be but once we just this
and this is they're inextricably tied
the the modern the progressive left and
the self-esteem movement you are not
going to find any conservatives any
right-wingers any libertarian saying you
shouldn't be able to use a red pen in a
test because I'd hurt somebody's
feelings okay maybe some kind of all
trite populist but no conservatism is
about rugged individualism it is about
taking responsibility for your own
actions this modern self-esteem movement
100% the progressive regressive left to
use Dave Rubens phrase what's crazy
about is they just think they talk about
everyone is their self-esteem you should
feel good about yourself
yet as we saw today they don't believe
that you can accomplish anything we
talked about that earlier in the week
how their kind of ties between
masculinity and in limited government
and constitutionalism and femininity the
feelings and liberalism where you know
men don't tend to get as jealous about
as women tend to be more inspired by
inspire people yeah look there the
lifted and brought up right they don't
want to bring the people down right yeah
yeah
and then they don't travel and herds you
know the same way whether they well some
people do yeah they're called bikers
your bandanas not fooling anybody anyway
the point is there are ties there was
rugged individualism again I don't
believe that you can truly be a man and
Mock the idea as Michael Moore does of
pulling yourself up by your bootstraps
you're not a man you're a woman with a
slightly larger pouch that's what I
think that's how I see you
a man has got to believe that he can
provide for his family a man has got to
believe that he can rest on her laurels
a man has got to believe that he is
worth something and adds something
brings something to the table which part
of what makes what is the makeup of a
man I don't know microcosm level I don't
know I don't relate to because even like
if I have a just a bad day where I feel
like man I really phoned it in today I
don't sleep as well right I don't see
III sleep so much better knowing hey I
worked my butt off today yeah I mean it
accomplished something I can't imagine
going my whole life feeling like I
phoned it in right but I patted myself
on the back when I got home at night and
said hey I deserve this beer cuz I'm
gonna I'm gonna rest well not at all and
I don't relate to that at all Scheider
right as you Tec cider I am I eat it was
good I'm glad you enjoyed it about that
lying to you but that is true and you
know a good way for a wife
get a husband in a fight I know this and
I know it with my dad I know with any
man I know or a partner is if you feel
as though you've come up short and then
to say oh I'm sure you did great
oh I'm sure for a woman to say or edit
your partner for all of our listeners
out there Chad with a tool of you to say
I'm sure you did fine and you know that
they have no idea what the situation is
even if you do think that you were
screwed you get mad because it brings
hollow then he says I wasn't like don't
say that because you have no idea maybe
I did screw up now I didn't but maybe I
did but when you say that and then I
know and I tell you that I didn't screw
up and that I was dealt a bad hand today
and you say hey cheer up it rings hollow
yeah yeah just sit down there they're
like I don't want you to be chillier I
just want you to just I don't want you
doggie pile of my enemies hot and maybe
I'm maybe I really screwed up yeah and
it'll get it call it out exactly what
might call out but okay to certainly
bring forward you know hey so we should
use this better now on the flip side
women get mad at that everyone knows
that women getting over they go listen I
just I just want to be able to vent and
I know that you're listening I don't
want you to offer solutions to problems
these are some of the biggest fights I
had with my wife in the first couple of
years she was I just need to know that
you're listening I don't need you to
offer solution whereas men feel better
if it's not there there but there's some
kind of solution oriented conversation
we know that this is a part of our of
our genetic makeup but self-esteem is
the there there it is the universal pat
on the back and these same people saying
they're there you should have
self-esteem are telling you you can't
pay for your own health care you need
the government to create a mandate you
need publicly funded insurance they're
saying you can't say for your own
retirement you need Social Security you
need the government to tell you how to
save your money they're telling you that
you can't find a good job but you can't
move up it's the 1% this car that you
hide your stack against you you've been
dealt a bad hand you need us but by the
way you should feel good you can
accomplish nothing without us don't you
feel good about yourself there's nothing
wrong with femininity either but isn't
it funny how at least is purely
anecdotal but all the really super far
left social justice warrior type of
friends in my life people I know all of
them have strands of femininity that
they present and the way they carry at
themselves out they they're there
catmen yeah they are and it's like there
are some weird parallels there between
and there's at the wrong feminity when
it's a woman and that in marriage works
great and you can you should make it it
could be a beautiful thing because
consoling is important especially that
balance with kids men can be pretty
harsh with kids sure I know my dad was
that with me or be like well but you did
screw up though right you know you're a
kid you don't want anything yes it's
tough but his mom would be the there
there that's great but it's not great
when creating a society and this
self-esteem movement the big irony to me
is that it tells you you can't
accomplish anything and boy gee golly
shouldn't you feel great about it and I
think that if you believe that and if
you vote for the people who tell you
that you can't accomplish anything to me
again voting is it's just it's just like
voting with your dollar when you go and
you decide to buy something you're
putting in that voting booth it's like
today's modern sacrificing a ram there
aren't a lot of sacrifices there aren't
there are a lot of them there aren't a
lot of moments of permanence today a
vote is one of them or you put that in
there and you don't get it back you are
voting right there you are truly putting
a stamp on it this is what I believe and
if you put a stamp on and say this is
what I believe I believe that everybody
else has to cover my mistakes I believe
that I can't provide for my family and
myself I believe that society's job to
Burt to shoulder the burden for me I
don't think you should have self-esteem
we have gotten to the point it's still
the same its ties into everything it's
so crystal clear to think about this we
have people Netflix and Disney going
back in scrubbing scientific facts from
1990 science videos why because it could
hurt someone's self-esteem it's not well
the science was wrong it could hurt
someone's self-esteem so we're against
this bill because it could hurt
someone's self-esteem and they need all
this free stuff we need to go back and
remove this idea that that your
biological sex is determined by
chromosomes what cuz it could hurt
someone's self-esteem we don't believe
that people are capable of handling any
criticism or any opposing viewpoint
which is largely why Patrick Moore
atmospheric scientist our PhD in ecology
his debate requests go completely
unanswered from the left there's a
reason that we believe in a form of
voices that there's a reason that we
believe in a form of open debate because
most conservatives didn't have good
self-esteem and they're okay accepting
win lose or draw when my experience the
people I hang out with the Andrew
Clemens the Ben Shapiro is the people in
this room we don't expect to win every
time but we expect to be given a chance
at bat the progressive left wants you to
start at third base and tell you that
you've deserved it and you know that you
didn't even bunt you don't even get a
walk and that is something that is
incredibly corrosive I'm really glad to
see people rejecting it but I do want
you to think about as you move on in
your week and think about other people
in your lives other people who sit there
and talk about self-esteem or who might
be far leftist and anytime a
conversation comes up and you see this
this sort of this this congruent through
line of someone else needs to fix this I
don't believe in myself
this could offend somebody bring it in
on the self-esteem movement say well you
must really believe that these people
have no self-esteem what do you mean
well if you think someone's gonna kill
herself because of a bill 9 video you
really don't think a lot of the
transgender community what what what I
mean you must really think so a little
about yourself well what are you talking
about if you don't believe that you can
purchase health insurance at your age
what might might cost you about $120 a
month you must really think that you
can't provide what what what oh man gosh
you must really have no faith in your
abilities what do I mean you have a you
have a college degree but you're
demanding the government set some
arbitrary artificial minimum wage it's
going to cause hyperinflation because
you simply don't believe that you can
move up in the workplace that's sad have
you thought about seeing someone
what what what it all comes down to
people not believing in themselves and
telling everyone else that they should
believe in themselves and reach for the
stars there's a star well hold on let us
get that for you and I think that's no
way to live and that's why we do this
show and that's why we keep fighting
back that's why mug club exists you know
why because I think it's sad and I think
telling people that they deserve
self-esteem when it's not earned this is
a modern concept self-esteem if not
earned rings completely Hollow it's a
lie just like Ben Carson was talking
about we talked about that this week
with with that urban housing he said
thank you my stroke Mountain factor
well he said no we don't want to make it
super comfy want to encourage ambition
we want to encourage people to get out
of these situations to provide someone
with a life of comfort but with no
ambition under the guise of hey you
should feel good about yourself no
matter what is to rob someone of like
what not get your stuff but is to rob
someone of the most basic and the
greatest joys that life has to offer I
think that don't Rob yourself of it
don't shortchange yourself we'll see you
next week Mudd Club members on Monday
Thursday for the cheapskates
[Music]